that's a funny we brought up look-alikes
cuz I was gonna launch a new segment
today I'm sure I'm not the only one but
I always get tagged in like pictures
videos of people that look like
everybody on here so we'll just go
through some of the the look-alikes that
people find or post and we'll pick a
winner and maybe send them some crap I
find in the back ok my crap do you mean
your underwear uShip a little sugar
skank with movement yeah yeah for why my
guy didn't the Rams draft him do you
know his name is Oscar
no really he did America audition for
America's Got Talent
Wow yes they say he has talent yeah
anybody can have that a man in a man
with four dogs on there and they're like
oh that's Talent Wow Oh big guy with
sweat yes he got buns okay boys and he
seems so well so thick mildly homoerotic
as well just mildly
his legs are oh [ __ ]
let me get that sofa cushion brother but
you could lose some coins in here man
yeah you can find a couple skittles up
in there
that's nice sweet and [ __ ] yeah boy yes
a little sugar interstate that's cool
though yeah he's famous in Arizona he
does the choreography for like the
Rattlers dancers and I think the
Cardinals dancers I don't shadow Kliff
Kingsbury - there's no more AFL they've
won championships to work yes sure they
did Chappelle so but who else does oh
he's out of a job if he just works with
her antlers no he's like what is he
doing Chappelle choreography okay I'm
just trying to get to the bottom of this
it's suspect
well yeah first of all the Rattlers have
to play real snakes I say you get an A
to them out there you get
realize [ __ ] snakes out there let's
see you soon that's what I like about a
lot of these teams stealing people's
names you know like the Penguins put
them real [ __ ] penguins on ice yeah
get them [ __ ] out there huh
[ __ ] hit up you know light up a sweet
little [ __ ] dab of meth next to a
couple penguins brother see these pings
get yeah and get them ice [ __ ] out
there but the CEOs ooh man I think we'll
[ __ ] bite your damn toes off one at a
time oh they're saying he looks like
Chappelle yeah you posted that video and
I got tagged so much everybody I was
Chappelle and here's someone saw Theo at
the carnival actually Jimmy Hutchins did
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Wow and the juxtaposition of
it's an eclipse going on it is June it's
always June 22nd
I don't know I feel like that young man
could definitely you guys could be each
other a little more cushion for the bus
around the tummy yeah he seemed like a
little softer yeah a little more Brown
yeah it's you if you can't do a back
flip yeah there we go
yeah it's you if you're into video game
set of cheerleading yeah okay and that
was me at Theo's origin story and this
one
someone saw Brandon getting some work
done
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
welcome to the bomb and then I think we
got one [ __ ] boy I can't even look at
you stuff I was like come over and sing
that song late at night you feel me
Stefan awake you like happy I know but
we still gonna celebrate we didn't
practice it why are you whispering
that's just how I talk I got 70% of my
voice taken out
and we got one more and we got someone
saw Chappell getting some groceries this
one is probably the most sent in and
that's risky to doing a Walmart
depending what city shop for way less
said yeah praise God brother I so I
think we have a clear winner for cats in
the wild today it was before I get this
bottom before I get my bottom sewn open
with the chance you hooked me up with
that I like how he has them titty
implants on his ass I'll tell you right
now zero presenter shoutout Arizona man
yeah shut out Stockton shut out a shot
to Germany where Stefan yes a doubt
still got more on the wild side with
Stefan I think yeah yeah his beard did
look drawn on mm-hmm oh he's been
through he's been through a lot we got
to get him in here
[Laughter]
joking around by him seeing you happy
birthday
don't you want that stunt double breath
oh look at Weiner stunt dog unless they
do a [ __ ] Brokeback Mountain - I
don't think you get the part if you do
whatever man I've been watching hey dude
reruns all alright
god bless y'all man
[Music]